[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend ihnen allen kurze
unterbrechung der sportberichterstattung
aus münchen um sie in den kommenden zehn
minuten auf den aktuellen nachrichten
stand zu bringen unter anderem mit
diesen themen
eklat nach holocaust vergleich
bundeskanzler scholz bedauert seine
späte reaktion auf die worte des
palästinenserpräsidenten
zwischen trauma und hoffnungen noch
schlagen raketen in odessa ein die
gefahr eines russischen großangriffs
scheint aber erstmal gewandt
und verteilungskampf auf der straße wie
gesetze und vorschriften den ausbau der
radwege behindern
[Musik]
holocaust bezeichnet den massenmord an
etwa sechs millionen juden während der
nazi herrschaft
entsprechend groß ist die empörung des
palästinenserpräsident abbas gestern auf
einer
pressekonferenz in berlin israel vor war
50 holocaust an palästinensern begangen
zu haben auch der bundeskanzler wird
kritisiert weil er nicht unmittelbar ein
schritt sondern erst später reagierte
dann allerdings deutlich andreas künast
hat details
man wird kanzler scholz gewarnt haben es
war sein erstes treffen mit
palästinenserpräsident abbas aber nicht
dessen erste entgleisung auch diesmal
dauert die pressekonferenz nur 14
minuten bis abbas die israelische
politik als apartheid bezeichnet hier
reagiert scholz und widerspricht ich
will ausdrücklich hier an dieser stelle
sagen dass ich mir das wort apartheid
nicht zu eigen mache zehn minuten später
wirft abbas israel noch mehr vor noch
unsägliches 50 massaker habe israel seit
seiner staatsgründung begangen und 50
holocaust
dass scholz diesmal nichts entgegnet
dass er abbas schweigend die hand gibt
und geht löst heftige empörung aus es
ist der aufreger auf allen titelseiten
israel am tag danach bedauert der
regierungssprecher wie er sagt seinen
fehler er habe die pressekonferenz zu
früh beendet sie haben gesehen dass der
bundeskanzler mich beim abgang von der
bühne schon kurz angeraunzt hat dass ich
das etwas schnell gemacht habe und er
gerne noch etwas entgegnet hätte die
kritiker überzeugt diese erklärung nicht
wenn ich eine pressekonferenz habe dann
kann ich die trotzdem weiterlaufen
lassen auch wenn sie erst mal beendet
war man hätte den stopp machen können er
das sagen kann ich habe noch etwas zu
sagen scholz sagt noch etwas auf twitter
ich bin zutiefst empört über die
unsäglichen aussagen des präsidenten
abbas gesendet auf deutsch englisch und
hebräisch
im nachhinein sicherlich keiner möchte
der situation seien sofort reagieren zu
müssen aber hier wäre es adäquat gewesen
sofort und unverständnis verständlich
sich zu äußern das lässt heute mitteilen
er habe die singularität des holocaust
nicht leugnen wollen
fragen wir unsere
hauptstadtkorrespondenten chaco dollar
berner die welcher schaden ist da
entstanden der schaden liegt in dem
eindruck der entstanden ist nämlich dass
man in deutschland im beisein des
bundeskanzlers unwidersprochen den
holocaust relativieren kann da versucht
man heute in berlin auch alles diesen
eindruck wieder aus der welt zu schaffen
der vertreter der palästinensischen
autonomiebehörde wurde ins kanzleramt
einbestellt und zur rede gestellt der
bundespräsident hat sich noch einmal
kritisch zu wort gemeldet und die
aussagen von abbas gerügt und
bundeskanzler scholz hat für morgen ein
telefonat mit dem israelischen premier
rapid angekündigt und eingeplant und
daran erkennt man schon dass man sich
des schadens durchaus bewusst ist und
versucht ihn eben hier zu begrenzen was
aber eben bleibt ist dieser moment in
dem olaf scholz sich lieber ins
protokoll gehalten hat als noch einmal
die pressekonferenz neu zu eröffnen und
zu sagen wartet noch mal alle einen
moment ich möchte noch mal etwas sagen
und dann die entscheidenden sätze zu
sagen die er jetzt eben hinterher
schiebt das ist ein zögern gewesen das
jetzt mit großem diplomatischen aufwand
wieder ausgebügelt werden muss
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
berlin und aller berner wie war das
palästinenserpräsident abbas und der
eklat um seinen holocaust vergleich die
pressekonferenz als video und weitere
politische reaktionen finden sie in
unserer zdf heute app
die anhaltende dürre in deutschland
belastet die verkehrswege notfalls
sollen kohletransporte wegen
niedrigwasser auf die schiene verlegt
werden dann könne es dazu kommen dass am
ende auch ein personenzug warten muss
sagt bundesverkehrsminister wissing denn
die versorgung der kraftwerke sei
vorrangig
seit
175 tagen bombardiert russland die
ukraine im moment ohne große
fortschritte schauen wir auf den
frontverlauf hier in orange markiert das
russische vormarsch gebiet die jüngsten
explosionen werden aus cardiff und der
region bonn jetzt gemeldet eine rakete
soll die hafenstadt odessa getroffen
haben dort sprach unser reporter henner
hebestreit mit einem geistlichen der
sich für kriegsopfer einsetzt und dafür
schikaniert wurde die strandsaison in
odessa fällt dieses jahr aus wegen des
krieges bleiben die anlagen hier leer
das baden im schwarzen meer des wegen
der gefahren treiben terminen sogar
verboten nur ein paar angler trauen sich
ans wasser
wir sitzen auf einer zeitbombe das macht
immer noch angst und weiß nie was im
nächsten augenblick passiert
jederzeit kann ein geschoss einschlagen
diese ferienhausanlage besser wurde in
der nacht wohl zufällig getroffen
russische raketen gelten als nicht sehr
zielgenau die sorge vor einer groß
angelegten landungsoperation nimmt
allerdings ab euro wurde eine motion
lustig zurzeit hat der feind nicht
genügend luft im unterstützung und kann
auch am land nicht genügend truppen und
material nach führen um eine landung von
see her zu riskieren
luis ag moskau oder st und so beginnt
die aufarbeitung dramatischer ereignisse
der letzten monate priester wazir hatte
mit anderen geistlichen direkt zu
kriegsbeginn versucht gefallene von der
schlangen insel zu bergen und geriet
dabei in russische gefangenschaft und
mit elektroschocks misshandelt
das haben sie uns korrekt behandelt aber
nach dem rückzug ihrer truppen aus
dagegen von kiew haben sie angefangen
uns zu misshandeln es ging ihnen nicht
um informationen sie wollten uns quer
durch das radio tor
erst nach 70 tagen kam er zurück nach
odessa die ukrainische
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt gegen
die verantwortlichen in russland
die usa investieren künftig hunderte
milliarden dollar in den klimaschutz so
viel wie nie zuvor in der us geschichte
nach langem politischen kampf
unterzeichnete präsident biden das
entsprechende gesetzespaket
vorgesehen sind rund 370 milliarden
dollar für energiesicherheit und den
kampf gegen die erderwärmung
der kongress hatte das gesetz vergangene
woche verabschiedet es gilt als großer
erfolg für beiden und seine demokraten
auch ex-präsident trump kann einen
erfolg feiern bei den vorwahlen der
republikaner zum us-kongress scheiterte
lässt amy einem seiner schärfsten partei
internen kritikerinnen die 56 jährige
tochter des ehemaligen vize-präsidenten
abstimmung und wird daher kein
abgeordnetenmandat mehr bekommen sie
unterlag harriet allgemein deren
kandidatur von job unterstützt wurde
wichtiges thema heute beim
verkehrsgerichtstag in goslar wie kann
fahrrad fahren sicherer werden die zahl
der gefahrenen radkilometer steigt seit
jahren von 82 millionen pro tag im jahr
2002 auf zuletzt 112 millionen kilometer
und das ziel im nationalen
radverkehrsplan eine verdopplung bis zum
jahr 2030 dafür braucht es allerdings
deutlich mehr und vor allem auch sichere
radwege christian von rechenberg und max
kolter
fahrradfahren bleibt ein risiko in
deutschland die zahl der verletzten und
toten im straßenverkehr sinkt seit 20
jahren konstant außer war den radfahrern
dass -unfall thema spielt sich im
wesentlichen im kreuzungsbereich ab
immer da wo man sich zwangsläufig
begegnet kommt es zu problemen begegnung
vermeiden moderne rad straßen wie hier
in münster wo autos nur zu gast sind
müssen bereit sein müssen also auf die
fahrbahn das geht nicht ohne konflikt da
muss das auto beispielsweise auch
parkraum abkleben zugunsten werden des
umweltverbundes oder hier wie in diesem
falle zu gunsten des fahrrades doch so
etwas lässt die geltende
straßenverkehrsordnung nicht ohne
weiteres zu gerichte genehmigen projekte
wie diese in der regel nur wenn die
gemeinde eine gefahr für die sicherheit
der radfahrer an einer bestimmten stelle
nachweisen kann und zwar durch
verkehrszählung und unfallstatistiken
viele projekte scheitern daran es muss
also erst was passieren bevor etwas
passiert so kritiker das gesetz als
bremser der bund in der pflicht zunächst
einmal würde ich erwarten dass das
bundesverkehrsministerium jetzt rangeht
und die straßenverkehrsordnung des
straßenverkehrs gesetz novelliert es
soll rat freundlicher werden belange wie
klima gesundheit und städtebauliche
entwicklungen berücksichtigen der adac
sieht es kritisch dafür gibt es eigene
gesetze und es zu vermengen mit der
straßenverkehrs gesetzgebung das halten
wir nicht für richtig es besteht nämlich
dann die gefahr dass wir einen flecken
flickenteppich an regelungen haben ohne
sicherheit auch keine verkehrswende
sagen experten jeder verletzte oder tote
radfahrer sei einer zu viel der druck
auf die politik wächst
und jetzt noch die zahlen vom
mittwochslotto sie lauten 1 17 29 34 44
46 und die superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 5
heute nacht und morgen drohen gewitter
wo besonders erfahren sie gleich von
katja schäfer das heute journal um
zwanzig vor elf mit bettina schausten
hier übernimmt morgen jana pareigis
alles gute ihnen auf wald und weiter
viel freude bei den european
championships aus münchen
[Musik]
guten abend von westen sind heute
schauer und gewitter heran gezogen das
ging schon am vormittag hier im
westlichen niedersachsen los und auch in
baden württemberg gab es schon die
ersten schauer und gewitter und jetzt
formieren sich neue gewitter über
frankreich und der schweiz und die
ziehen im laufe der nacht weiter nach
nordosten erreichen baden württemberg
das südliche hessen rheinland pfalz und
das saarland und die gewitter in
norddeutschland ziehen langsam nordwärts
ab die temperaturen heute nacht sinken
auf werte zwischen 19 und 14 grad und
morgen ist es im südwesten etwas kühler
mit 22 bis 27 grad noch mal heiß wird es
dagegen in berlin und brandenburg bei 34
35 grad jedenfalls bevor dort die
gewitter ankommen die toben sich morgen
hier im nordosten aus und vielleicht
blitzt es auch mal an der ostsee
kräftige gewitter mit unwetterpotenzial
also hagel platzregen und sturmböen gibt
es aber auch im südwesten und an den
alpen kann es freitag und samstag
insgesamt mehr als 100 liter regen pro
quadratmeter geben der sonntag wird
deutlich ruhiger guten abend